LeBron James has finally spoken out
about Mondays celebration of life for
Kobe and Gianna Bryan multiple NBA
players were in attendance including
LeBrons Laker teammates but during the
ceremony as several well-known faces
were being shown on the screens there
was no sign of LeBron he was also not
photographed at the Staples Center which
has caused fans to speculate about
whether or not he was even there during
Tuesday's basketball practice the Los
Angeles Times acts the 35 year old if he
attended the memorial
LeBron responded by saying quote I
respect your question for sure it was
very emotional very emotional day very
tough day for myself for my family for
everyone involved the NBA player didn't
clearly answer the question but he did
make it a point to praise Kobe's wife
Vanessa Bryant for her strength that day
saying quote the one thing I can come
out of this saying is how strong and how
bold and how powerful vanessa is to
stand up there the way she did to give
the speech the way she gave that speech
I commend her my heart is with her
family still with his three daughters
that's still here with his wife with his
mom and dad his sister it was just a
very difficult day obviously celebration
but it was a difficult day for all of us
I'd appreciate if we can move on tonight
that would be great
the LA Times went on to acts of weather
the memorial could help the team start
moving on from their grief LeBron
responded by saying there will never be
closure the night before Kobe Bryant
died in a helicopter crash he attended
the Lakers game to congratulate LeBron
on surpassing him on the NBA's all-time
scoring list the late NBA stars last
tweet was a message of respect to LeBron
for his accomplishment after news of
Kobe's death broke LeBron was seen an
obvious emotional distress arriving at
LAX he took to his Instagram the next
day to express his sadness saying quote
please give me the strength from the
heavens above and watch over me
I got us here there's so much more I
want to say but just can't right now
because I can't get through it until we
meet again my brother
LeBron delivered a touching speech when
the Lakers returned to the court for
their first game after Kobe's death he
even got a tattoo that says mom before
life to honor his friend about a week
before a Kobe's public memorial eats he
was at the NBA all-star practice in
media day in Chicago where LeBron opened
up about how Kobe is a sensitive subject
for him
right now I mean we know that he's
watching over us
and you know it's not responsibility to
just represent the purple and go not
only for him before all the greats
everybody has never come to the Late
Show
so I don't want it I really don't want
to sit up here and talk about it too
much you know it was very very sensitive
subject but he's with he's with us every
day
[Music]
you